doctor strange captain america iron man
what do they all have in common mcu
characters that i'm about to analyze for
their medical accuracy
[Music]
that's clearly a case of
cosmotosis where uh the cosmos actually
penetrates your skin
i think that was legally your fault get
the first aid kit do me a favor and
don't be dead
does he need cpr because i totally know
cpr thank you for offering to do chest
compressions but a person who's awake
and alert does not need cpr because
their heart is beating otherwise they
will not be functioning you
what realm is this
alpheim gohenheim new mexico
you death threatened me thor was so
punior
oh
that's a taser everything in your body
is essentially an electric process and
when you get zapped with 50 000 volts
you essentially lose control of all of
those processes therefore you collapse
hi
just taking a little blood how dare you
attack the son of hope you need some
help
oh
i don't want to get hit by thor
see if i i was in there i would be
boxing him
that looks like they gave him a short
acting benzodiazepine probably sometimes
we used to do promethazine haloperidol
but the benzos seem to work a little
faster and better ladies and gentlemen
today we take not another step towards
annihilation but the first step
on the path to peace
we begin with a series of micro
injections into the subject's major
muscle groups
the serum infusion
will cause immediate cellular change i
mean the reason we do all our injections
well not all our injections so we do
some underneath the skin layer but we
also do intramuscular injections for
things that need to be rapidly absorbed
to stimulate growth
the subject will be saturated
with vitality i hope it's clear that
this is fantasy there's no thing that
you can inject into muscles and just
make them explode the only thing that is
somewhat similar to this is synthol
which is an oil that i've talked about
in the past that some tick tockers use
to make their muscles appear really big
but they're not functionally big meaning
they're not stronger by any means
and that's a huge amount of serum to
inject into each of his little muscles
like he's going to be edematous if
anything
[Music]
if you only knew
how many times
i looked up this image of his body and
his workout
so i can get his pecs because i was
obsessed with this look like this is my
dream body right here damn you chris
even the haircut's fire
whoa
that's a bomb baby
damage to his tympanic membrane is
definitely a happening explosion's so
close
to you like ow
oh and he's bleeding that's not a good
area to bleed from because that's where
the heart is
who's performing surgery with a patient
awake that's just torture
do they chloroform him that's so evil
and the only reason i say it's evil is
because like chloroforming someone by
allowing them to inhale it by putting a
napkin over it that's doused in it it's
not uniform you don't know how much dose
you're giving you don't know how long
they're going to be knocked out for my
worst fear waking up in the middle of a
surgery i think that's everyone's worst
fear we just don't think about it often
that's an ng tube not sure why he has an
ng tube an ng tube is a nasogastric tube
that runs from your nose into your
stomach to either pull fluids out or
it's to feed him because he can't eat on
his own
it does come out like that so that is
accurate just kind of gross watching it
and this is where the medical accuracy
ends fantasy begins
what i did is to save your life
i removed all the shrapnel i could
there's a lot left and it's headed into
your atrial septum the atrial septum is
essentially the separation between the
the two top components of the heart now
if there's shrapnel there if it's not
causing a problem i guess you could
leave it but i'll understand how it can
enter into the septum and not cause
severe bleeding in the heart between the
atria or at least out of the atria into
the pericardial space what is this that
is an electromagnet
hooked up to a car battery
and it's keeping the shrapnel from
entering your heart basically what he's
saying is he's trying to keep the piece
of metal shrapnel inside the actual meat
of the organ as opposed to the
circulation part of the organ so it
doesn't get shot out into the general
circulation end up doing more damage
like if it starts going into the brain
that's lethal
oh my god is that the thing that's
keeping you alive it was it is now an
antique
this is what will be keeping me alive
for the foreseeable future i'm swapping
it out for an upgraded unit i don't know
what that monitor is showing behind us
is it safe yeah it should be fine it's
like operation you just don't let it
touch the socket wall
people what do you mean it's just a game
never mind great game okay
great
maybe take your ring off first you know
i i i don't think that i'm qualified to
do this yet you feel qualified to give
very inaccurate advice on goop.com very
interesting
what is it gsw gsw means gunshot wound i
don't know why we say gsw when it's
actually more syllables than gunshot
wound it's impinging on the medulla i
needed a specialist nick diagnosed brain
death
something about that doesn't feel right
to me we have to run a bullet in the
brain stem is dangerous for so many
reasons mostly because the brain stem
controls your respiratory rate your
heart rate all these autonomic functions
if they're not active you can't just
think heartbeat heartbeat breathe in
heartbeat heartbeat breathe in stomach
work they didn't happen automatically
you die you need to get a prep for a
suboccipital cranial not gonna let you
operate on a dead man what do you see
a bullet a perfect bullet it's been
hardened you harden a bullet by alloying
lead with antimony toxic metal and
that's leached directly into the
cerebral spinal fluid wrap it on said
central nervous system shut down you
gotta go he's basically saying some kind
of metal from the bullet is impacting
his central nervous system therefore
he's not really dead he's acting like
he's brain dead and he's gonna save his
life by removing the bullet by doing a
radical procedure
only in a marvel movie
cranial nerves intact
[Music]
those look like alligator forceps i love
using those to get earwax out of
patients ears especially when it's like
hard and you could go in there and just
like grab it
so satisfying
[Music]
okay okay this is really funny this is
really really funny and i'm not a
surgeon i've never worn this device but
looking at this image the things he's
wearing on his glasses to get a better
view are they not covering his field of
vision and then the actual lenses are
lower than his eyes oh my god he can't
see through those
you send me the
got it
[Music]
[Applause]
who wants a surgeon that is getting
pictures of patient records on their
lamborghini and then crashing their car
[Music]
looks like he has a lot of fractures in
his hands
requiring some kind of orthopedic device
with pins and needles i've never seen it
on the outside like this this is very
exaggerated but remember the bones in
the hand are quite small the carpals are
very small so putting in pins is not
always a simple process especially the
big size pins that they have there
it's going to take a lot of physical
therapy so shout out to physical
therapists but also occupational
therapists as well because when it comes
to rehabbing the hands you got to think
about fine motor control especially for
him as a surgeon show me his strength
this is him getting that therapy i was
just talking about
this is useless if the patient is
struggling this much we have to decrease
the intensity of whatever therapy we're
doing it's about allowing them to do it
successfully several times and then
increasing that intensity as time goes
on have you ever known anyone with nerve
damage this severe to do this and
actually recover one guy yeah
factory accident broke his back
paralyzed his leg wasted away he came in
three times a week a few years later he
walked past me on the street what yeah
what
show me his file it take me a while to
pull the files from the archive you
can't just show people patient records
come on guy hipaa but if it proves your
arrogant ass wrong he is an arrogant ass
and as a surgeon like dr strange you
should know that people recover from
severe strokes traumas
tumors and regain neurological function
the progress that patients make under
the care of pmnr physical medicine and
rehabilitation physicians is truly
magical it goes to show that the human
body has an amazing capacity to heal
itself that's the principle of
osteopathic medicine that we live by and
it's not because i love that principle
it's because it's true
christie
[Music]
stephen oh my god we're having an
operating career now just you
no i haven't had time for you you can't
just run into a hospital and request an
operating theater what happened stabbed
courtney i can't put on how does he know
he has cardiac tamponade if you've been
stabbed you can actually die from
cardiac tampon but how he knows that
without doing an echo listening for
heart sounds and all this other stuff i
have no idea
just kevin is clear i don't know what
she just did to know that the chest
cavity is clear she went
okay this is the non-medically accurate
part of the show
if someone has a pneumothorax where
their lung collapses and you're sure of
it you could put a needle into the
second intercostal space which will
allow you to allow that air to come out
normalizing the pressure allowing the
lung to re-expand
whoa we don't do it like that bro can
you imagine if we just like are like
okay i'm putting it in and you have to
make sure you're palpating the area as
you do it you're not just like stabbing
randomly from far away like by holding
it from so far away you have very little
control of where you're actually putting
the needle
okay he's flatlining if she takes out
the paddles i will scream
she's taking out the paddles stop
charging them you don't shock a sicily
shots compressions chest compression
chest
clearly they need this this is the chest
compressions university merch two inches
deep 100 per minute please do chest
compressions when someone's heart stops
not run to shock them you can also buy
this merch down below
here's the truth about your underwear
click here to check that out as always
stay happy and healthy but is your
underwear healthy click here to check
that out
[Music]